hi guys I'm Greg I'm John guys the Flash
movie this movie which isn't having to
smooth this process of all that dec film
so far was getting a rewrite from the
King Arthur scribal Manning Arthur
scribe is a screenwriter producer named
Joby Harold if you guys don't know he is
a talented director screenwriter of the
film awake oh yeah stars Jessica Alba
and um Hayden Hayden Christensen who
gave us a famous Sam line that everyone
looks at make fun the film if you put
the numbers in Reverse thirty-two
percent oh boy that's ten percent higher
ten percent higher than the 23 actually
gets so little better than what you
might think yeah so he's also one of the
couple of screenwriters who lived I
repeat edge of tomorrow I don't know why
they keep changed and he wrote King
Arthur legend of the sword which we have
no idea how that's going to be so but
okay he wrote that the flash project is
consistently getting a little bit more
and more worried a different red
primarily because the Flash movie has a
lot to live up to you know this show is
amazing the show is incredible and fans
love it and fancy don't even really care
for the other CW shows a lot of them
will so big I like the flash so the
flash is a really cool show having like
that be the most successful DC live
adaptation show and then now making a
movie that's separate from it there's a
lot to live up to because if this movie
sucks i feel like people might be like
yet you should have just gotten two
people from the show to do the movie or
something or connected in somewhat be
having a cool Director Rick fumigation
what's his name having you want a family
you uh I just read like the first couple
hours and I go it sounds like this today
and Seth grahame-smith who is the judge
who did Abe Lincoln vampire hunt another
fantastic movie so yeah it's a weird
that it is they're going with this
announcing that this guys doing I don't
know what that means because
theoretically you could argue it's like
starting off with the with seth
grahame-smith that suggests to me one
kind of movie moving to rick from he was
like a different kind of movie and now
like at least having seen the King
Arthur trailer and having seen that this
guy's writing like Robin Hood next I I
don't know it seems like they got
themselves a guy who's writing a lot of
franchise so I don't see a track record
that's super strong as I even feel like
a lot of the screenwriting credibility a
[ __ ] tomorrow because there's like a
couple of riders on it it tends to lean
towards Christopher McCrory at the end
of the day like well Dennis awesome
maybe because he's the most famous known
writer out of them or something and I
don't know how much like doug liman had
like sleigh over how that script shaped
up but it seems like he's the name you
hear you know in heavy involvement
without what that movie is down the back
way we've been taking this writer who
doesn't really seem to have that strong
of a track record it's like okay cool
he's doing other big movies that doesn't
really mean that this is going to be
like even better now I mean guys look I
get it though because the more riders
you have on a script that better the
film tend to be that's really in a way
movies go right this to me at least just
judging by the rotten tomatoes page of
his pedigree but Joby yeah I don't know
like the movies that he's got coming out
could be cool awake didn't get your very
good reviews but I like the concept this
to me suggests that they want a guy who
they can just give an assignment and he
will recount it to them yeah exactly I
feel like that the original writer
aground my big fan of abraham lincoln
vampire hunter but the dope director
it's not like they wanted to do
something different and weird women get
both of those choices or at least two
little way even if Abe Lincoln is in a
perfect movie it's still like oh yeah
this is the same thing yeah but this guy
I don't know I feel like it's on me yeah
DC just copies how to keep down these
production problems and yeah good it you
shouldn't be a hate I shouldn't is that
simple stop guys like I don't understand
like either get filmmakers or don't
like this make up your mind like do you
know how to work with the kinds of
filmmakers you're bringing it here like
you're bringing in these guys who are
kind of individual and they'd be like
whoa whoa whoa we can't work with you
and visited like the way you want you
seem like they want a guy like this
maybe it'll be the right match so how do
you guys feel about the Flash movie
that's far are you still excited for it
what is your faith level on a scale of
one to ten let's go with that let's go
with that well then it pays from one
rewrite two things going to just like
start from scratch which makes the quote
in this article really confusing where
they're like guys we're gonna take
everyone's ideas like are you now cuz
you're it sounds like you're throwing
all those out and rewriting all the
ideas I mean the obvious choice would be
just get zack snyder to direct it
definitely yeah he makes DC and
everything better it made so much BDS
resident was the best DC as ever given
yeah I don't think it could possibly get
any better name name one movie name one
we eat my wire to the relaunch of the DC
EU and after DC you got launched you
can't think of one mm-hmm barring any
movies before after bad members Superman
naval one CBS at the top at the top of
that goes like Ray vs Suicide Squad dark
knight returns man of steel batman
forever yeah you know that and the worst
definitely like it's not about me in the
dark knight a sub deposit was blind ones
got dark eyes oh god yeah we're gonna
bring over rated over latest piece of
[ __ ] I'm glad they went in this
direction after the undeserved saxena
Dark Knight I kind of say Keith Ledger's
Joker is really underrated very over
radio like oh did act Nicholson oh and
ridiculous totally but so I like that
the dcu is bringing into the new rider
touch up the flat screw yeah give david
ayer two weeks to read scriptlet Jack
Zack Snyder director yeah that's amazing
dude David Ayer wrote the suicide squad
scripting
six weeks imagine he can do it too yeah
like with all that extra pressure like
that's what diamonds are [ __ ] yeah yeah
Oh DC DC is like is constantly playing
with my feelings of hope yeah he could
nap subscribe to well Rezac and check
out John on reason reasons to to Jerry
Twitter and Instagram he's a social
media manager of bloom houses sites and
the real rejects of the facebook it's a
real thing that I do you want to help
fast me I do whoa I'm a flash speedster
I've never little toy why I why did you
not tell me that you could use before I
can move really fast the prom is I
finish fast to buy jumper by Murphy
right right again I write a whole five
is secret and use reveal I am Iron Man